on se voit pas aller jusqu'à 64 ans
tirer des palettes ou prendre des colis
quoi tous les territoires de la
population française sont mobilisés même
dans les plus petits territoires
963000 personnes selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur et évidemment 2 millions et
demi selon les syndicats
mais oui clairement nous on a notre
propre comptage il est de combien il est
1,8 millions la mobilisation est
peut-être attendu mais au-delà des
estimations de la déchiffre il n'y a pas
vraiment une logique davantage ou des
avantages il y a une mobilisation il
faut pas être dans le déni il faut la
prendre en compte il faut l'entendre
c'est des mobilisations qu'elle
n'avaient jamais été atteintes depuis le
début des années 90 donc ça il faut en
prendre compte il se passe quelque chose
après la pression de la rue la menace
d'une France à l'arrêt au retour des
vacances le 7 mars si malgré tout le
gouvernement et les parlementaires
restaient sourds à la contestation
populaire
la terre syndicat l'appellerait les
travailleurs et les travailleurs les
jeunes et les retraités à durcir le
mouvement en mettant la France à l'arrêt
dans tous les secteurs le 7 mars
prochain je crois pas que ce soit leur
intérêt que demain nos enfants puissent
plus aller à l'école que les Français
puissent plus prendre un métro un bus en
Transilien
de paralysie de blocage et bloquer le
pays à mon avis ce serait
contre-productif pour ce que eux-mêmes
veulent porter si hors berger au santé
le pays et santé les vibrations du pays
je pense que ça serait ça se verrait
actuellement et là en l'occurrence ils
sont complètement à côté de ce qui est
en train de se passer dans le pays qui
est vraiment une espèce de colère sourde
mais une colère absolument déterminée on
appelle avec la France à l'arrêt ça
s'appelle ouais ça veut dire à faire des
choses qui existent par exemple en
Espagne par exemple des commerçants qui
baissent leur salut en ce moment qui
baisse leur rideau au moins
symboliquement pendant une heure ou deux
je répète comme le président de la
République la c que nous pouvons
entendre qu'il y a une opposition c'est
la démocratie mais que l'opposition ne
passe pas nécessairement par le blocage
du pays est-ce qu'il y a encore des
gestes possibles oui ah
bien sûr on est à l'écoute ça veut dire
aussi plus de transport ça veut dire
aussi oui bien sûr comme d'ailleurs bah
oui parce que les salariés les salariés
du transport
le film vaincre mourir est un succès en
salle il comptabilise déjà plus de 200
000 entrées depuis sa sortie le 27
janvier l'épopée de charrette n'a pas
été au goût de tout le monde et
notamment de la presse de gauche à ces
électeurs électriques attention parce
que
ne vous trompez pas de combat vous avez
mal votre pompe pas de combat pardon
vous avez mal voté vous allez leur dire
non je leur dis oui je pense qu'ils ont
une responsabilité dans le vote qu'ils
ont posé ça j'ai pas de problème avec ça
des Français sont complices de la montée
du fascisme en France je le pense je ne
m'attendais pas du tout à ce procès en
révisionnisme historique que une
certaine presse a fait au film au moment
de sa sortie
au point que vraiment voilà c'était
presque à se demander s'ils avaient vu
le film ou s'ils avaient pas écrit la
critique sur la base juste du spectacle
donné au Puy du Fou quoi vous avez été
comparé allez-vous à des personnages de
l'univers d'Harry Potter apparemment du
parti Renaissance qui a retiré assez
rapidement cette suite vendredi
après-midi Marine Le Pen était Voldemort
la chef des mangemort et vous une
mandragore sont 87 à embarquer ce matin
à Marseille direction la Turquie des
sapeurs-pompiers et des sauveteurs de la
sécurité civile moi je le reçois ça en
plus avec le caractère sexy selon lequel
ma voix est insupportable enfin je veux
dire au nom de quoi un parti politique
se permet-il ça au même moment à Roissy
45 tonnes de matériel médical et un
hôpital de campagne sont chargés prêts à
être envoyés dans la région dadiyaman
quand vous embrassez ce monsieur à
l'époque atteint du sida c'est une
manière en fait de dire voilà on peut
avoir peur on n'est pas forcément
préparé mais n'oubliez pas ce monsieur
est malade il ne faut pas l'exclure les
suites de l'enquête après l'accident de
la route impliquant Pierre Palmade
l'humoriste était sous l'emprise de la
cocaïne lorsque son véhicule a percuté
une voiture avec trois passagers du coup
je me demande si ça serait pas une bonne
idée d'embrasser un macroniste
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]